[Music]
a morning
it's time for another week of Wow where
I go through your submissions you ask
the content I have the questions roll
the intro leave your entries in the pros
let's see what you post to this week's I
wonder if there's going to be any chair
memes in there and yes I did I did
recently break out of prison you are
correct
who would win I have better graph ISM
but came history Wow could barely even
get started
Logan Paul makes a video showing a dead
body YouTube puts it in the trending
list
PewDiePie makes a 15 second response
video that doesn't show a dead body
violates Terms of Service I'm not gonna
call out YouTube for their blatant
favoritism when in fact the people
reuploading Logan Paul's video got taken
down and flagged with a strike but Logan
Paul's video was approved and not even H
restricted that's not favoritism
that's just stabbed die alright I'm just
I'm just glad YouTube is keeping you
know the same rules for everyone it
makes sense
it seems fair to me I'm sure Logan polls
show the thinning will be canceled just
like my show was cancelled as soon as
media attention gone into somebody touch
my hello hi I've been seeing this meme
just appear in a lot of different places
Assad on Twitter
okay scatter do me
falooda do awesome me just can't help
you say I gotta say these are pretty
good means you guys are learning you
guys are improving you're like you're
like an AI you can be taught well done
my heart resting exercising when
somebody touches perspective take all
these horrible things that happen
sexual harassment murder
but it went someone touched our
spaghetti that's when you know you have
to stand up and use your voice Ethan
impose did it before
goddamnit oh yeah oh yes learn the
difference
learn the difference this is a high
quality huh certainly a nice chair isn't
so expensive isn't it hypocritical
comebacks real-life Doki Doki I gently I
feel like we're gonna see these meme for
a long time a long time it's 2018 is a
good start of the oh my door is ringing
[Music]
yeah yeah explain this YouTube huh why
you touching my spaghetti spaghetti
Oh God that's pretty cool I love the
design so much I put it on my nails very
nice you know this is high-quality
design by yours truly see my chair
[Music]
if Marzian Felix don't work out I think
I found Peter pies go to girl why cuz
she has a sledgehammer everybody great
it's definitely Brad how to talk to
short people wrong correct realizing
you're halfway through the video and you
don't know what the f it's about because
you've been looking at the LEDs lights
for seven minutes straight that's that's
good to know that my channel is full of
audience of intellectuals who's not just
distracted by blinking that lights I'm
trying to put forth a nice message here
about the 2017 and you're just like oh
look shiny who would win a one white boy
or one long boy oh yeah but can wide boy
do this hopefully one day my back will
just crack and that will be my final
video okay we have uh huh okay somebody
touch my spaghetti brick it down now
girl
[Music]
yeah you know what I can do that if I
want you I won most handsome 2017 number
six on trending the worst gift of 2017
number seven on twenty on trendy wack
much better than yeah whatever I can't
even say it
cuz it's such a bad name I don't know
how you come up with such a terrible on
original name the why is supreme
champion thank you I don't really feel
comfortable letting other people do
stuff for me yet makes billions and
millions by letting fans do his work
imagine killing yourself and Logan Paul
is the one that finds your body I'd kill
myself
[Laughter]
[Music]
god I'm good god I'm good any time
you're losing an argument in anything if
you realize I'm probably gonna have to
use my trump card can you do it yeah
these Logan memes are dead someone
hanged herself recently I was pretty
bummed out about it but the total views
on my channel increased the memes are
they ladies so good like if someone's
spaghett when you go from being
internet's number one hated youtuber to
internet's second movie
spaghett men women deficient
goddamnit
we're under Darla's 390 man just 399 be
back smile sweet sister said oh no oh no
Logan why LA Logan live why why am i
drawing thank you for being yourself we
love you hashtag pitter-patter brofist
alms draws that's sick
very nice somebody did anyone else learn
math with these in elementary school we
had these for the special kids in class
respected women after all he's my
escaped beauty pay of course of course
guys I am the noises of the nicest I am
the top ten of the nicest if there was a
top ten nicest guy PewDiePie list
I definitely be tucked in babe I need
some money so bad
god damn it hell no this is
family-friendly Christian content right
yep and he doesn't break YouTube's
guidelines nope then if I publish it it
won't get you money chase that makes
sense to me publish the monitor yes yes
so it's like Oh everything is fine I'm
just gonna publish this now I sure hope
nothing bad happens
Logan oh my god that's a good meme right
there anyway that was another week of Oh
God remember to submit your memes in the
PD PI's submission subreddit it's the
greatest subreddit of all time this is
literally repeat this week with 20,000
that's insane
the memes are getting better I'm not
gonna lie the memes are getting better
okay we need more chair Lemmy nice chair
me
and more original content Who am I
kidding that's never gonna happen thank
you for watching another one leave a
like if you enjoy and the squad fill out
[Music]